so big question is how much is enough
because I think the reason Kim and I are
successful is we always started small we
actually stay small and we do keep doing
the same thing but we don't ever try to
get big we got big I think we got big by
staying small we did I mean our Core
group is very small and then we license
out so for those of you who think you
have to start some Mega company or be
you know make millions of dollars that's
not really true need motivation what's
up then with believe Nation hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's look one of the
best Robert Kiyosaki and my take on his
top 50 rules for success enjoy
the lesson is here you gotta choose your
teachers wisely when the market crashed
in 2008 guess how much money I borrowed
a lot
300 million no way
from private investors the banker how
does that how does that work because
interest rates were dropping and real
estate prices were going to the toilet
and when I walk into my banker this is
what Rich Dad Poor Dad about Richard
airport has about a financial statement
income statement balance sheet statement
of cash flow it's a book on accounting
people don't even know it's a book on
accounting so I walked into my bank with
my partner and had all this property
that was floating to the surface
and I say I'll take them off your hands
I just give give me the money to buy the
property wow
that's cojones 300 million
give me the money and I'll buy your
properties for you
that's crazy so it depends and this is
my whole thing I am now 700 million
almost a billion in debt really you know
why
because I don't pay any taxes the more
debt I have the less tax I pay
and the average guy goes how do you do
that because you have bad teachers
and so it's this whole thing that you
gotta choose your teachers wisely that's
why I wrote the book fake fake money
fake teachers fake assets I don't touch
that garbage that Wall Street puts out I
don't have a 401k I don't have stocks
mutual funds ETFs doesn't mean you
shouldn't but I don't need them
okay right and the other part is look
for young guys the best teachers are not
in colleges the best teacher are on
YouTube
the best teachers are on YouTube wake up
instead of young people the Millennials
you know you've been screwed
you know you're being left with a world
that's absolutely horrible shape
financially in all this student loan
debt pensions are collapsing Financial
systems are collapsing they're rich are
getting richer
but apparently uh somebody gave you
something to get yourself out of this
and what the Millennials have that I
didn't have was an iPhone
the iPhone is a single most powerful I
cannot believe how much power that thing
has so it seems to me I'm not really a
religious I'm not not political
but I'm saying that
God does provide some level and God
provided the Millennials with an iPhone
holy mackerel all you have to do is sink
your brain to that iPhone
you have more power than you and I ever
had when we were their age you know do
you know what I mean the trouble is if
they don't haven't gone to school and
they have a teacher
that is incompetent and we've all had
income competent teachers
their brain and the iPhone are not
synced into making money
you know what I mean there and if you
can't make money with your iPhone
there's something wrong in your brain
not the iPhone's brain I want to war
twice on the front lines yeah and I
changed what happened so I joined the
Marine Corps I got a flight full of
Pensacola I learned to fly I go to Camp
Pendleton I strap on my weapons I go to
Advanced weapons and Camp Pendleton I go
to Okinawa and then they send me into
Vietnam
and I I came out of Vietnam about four
months later back to back to re-stage in
Okinawa and I thought everybody had
changed
I looked at the fellow Marines and I
thought
and it wasn't that there were
I had been to war
you got tougher
it's different but when somebody's
trying to kill you every single Mission
I went down three times no way yeah and
I came back stronger and tougher so I
come back to Okinawa I got like a week
off and they're gonna ship me back into
Vietnam again I said what happened to
these guys and it wasn't that they
changed I changed so what happens to
entrepreneurs who go out and they get
their ass handled to them and they
survive if you survive you see the world
diplomats and that's what happened to
you when you got the Android and all
this yeah you see a different world
whereas um Peace time
whose climbing the corporate ladder
right now they just lost their job
they're sucking their thumb
you know this is the worst time for him
yet for a wartime leader that's very
excited they're excited about it yeah
it's the best of times yeah if you're an
entrepreneur right now the world's open
to you
you're an employee your world's dead to
you also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there well the Japanese had a thing
called kumiyai
was that we feel lived in the same
neighborhood in Hawaii and you live in
you're a Japanese all the Japanese stuck
together and my father who was six foot
four for Japanese is pretty big the
kumia would come and you know talk to
our family about the Japanese sticking
together my father threw them out and he
said he says look we're Americans get
that in your head right now
you know so I had I had this conflicting
cultural values sure
so again for every entrepreneur first
thing you must inspect is what was your
cultural heritage not that it's right or
wrong or the values yeah I made the my
usual wise ass remark only lazy people
use their own money
and that's because I have spent much of
my life raising Capital you know today
you have crowdfunding and all that stuff
but the reason I had to learn to raise
money was because I had no money
and so if you read Rich Dad Poor Dad in
there my my rich dad always said never
say I can't afford it
and was my Rich Dad and many of my
teachers subsequent to that
this had lazy people always say I can't
afford it
I don't have the money that's why
they're poor they have a poor mindset so
instead of figuring out how to raise
money it's just really easy to be a
loser and I call you losers it pisses
them off
because we all have the power if we
wanted to to not be poor if we learned
how to raise money if you're poor right
now
it was called look in the mirror doesn't
matter that always said to me says if
you're looking in the mirror right now
and you see a loser that's what you are
you can't make money in this economy
never change we are thinking you know
you know hindsight is 2020 as I said yes
yes so I was if you're looking you know
you don't have any money you don't have
a job
your boyfriend or girlfriend has left
you
and uh soon they go well how did I get
here
how did I get here it was a there was a
great book called uh you know Gulag
archipelago by Sultan Nathan so he gets
thrown in this in a
um
concentration camp or a gulag in Siberia
and he says how did I get here
you know how you got there
because he was a peacetime leader
um didn't fight back
so people are being sold adult go to
school
get a job pay taxes save money get out
of debt buy a house with your house is
an asset and invest for the long term in
a well-defined portfolio of stocks bonds
mutual funds and ETFs
and I do none of that I started my wife
and I started with a bookkeeper why a
bookkeeper because the number one thing
an entrepreneur must have is accurate
records I've made so many guys show up
and they said where are your records
They want me to fund their company they
don't have any records they have no
numbers
I said how do I know if you're good or
bad
well good man it's a good concept we're
doing a lot we're going to change the
world this is like a revolutionary
concept
we're good people yeah you know I have a
I have a masters in art yeah we're from
the same city you know I know yeah we
grew up together if you're not doing
well if you're not thriving today in
this crisis
then somebody tier ahead
somebody crawled upside your butt and
into your head and messed with it you
know go to the school get a job taxes
save money and get out of debt and
invest in the long term in a while
Diversified portfolios talk spots mutual
funds and ETFs if you've done that you
you're in big trouble so as you know if
you don't change your thoughts you don't
change your life and that's why I've
been uh you know I've been tweeting on
and I'm so old I don't know what Twitter
is
but anyway
uh what was I talking about oh I said go
to YouTube man there's some the best
teachers all right too and they're not
getting paid stupid academic rates you
know they don't have tenure they just
most of them if if they're a real
teacher they're doing really well today
you're doing well I'm doing well I would
listen to us not that phony and at
Harvard you know the the peace time
leader I don't know if it's good news
except to be careful
um you know what changed my life was a
book like it did for many people it was
this book here was called the brunch of
giants
as by Dr R Buckminster Fuller and grunt
stands for gross Universal cash Heights
so when I was I think in my 30s I went
to study with Fuller you know he's most
well known for the geodesic dome and I
first saw his geodesic dome
in Montreal Canada Expo 67 the World's
Fair of the future so my classmate from
school in New York we hitchhiked up to
Montreal
just to say Buck is Dome it was a U.S
Pavilion and it blew me away you know
and um
but we all have these events and
teachers in our lives and so I think the
good news is is that there's a teacher
like you online now the best teachers
are on YouTube not in schools anymore
and um I think that's really the good
news is what we're doing is the news
what's happening in the news today is
fake it's the old news
this um
it's tragic
this coronavirus you know like
I don't know if it's real I mean the
virus is real
but the media terrorism is frightening
so I've already been warned many times
to stay in my Lane don't go into
medicine
don't go into this virus stay teaching
people with my little cash flow game
you know I'm talking about stay small or
we'll stomp on you
so I just remember back in 19 so I I
first went to the dome in Montreal at
the World's Fair in 67.
and I studied at Fuller in 1981 and I
started in 81 82 and 83 and he was
predicting the future
yes he told us what was coming
and as I've said many times many people
it's not what I want to do I don't do
what I love
I ask myself what does God want done
and what God wants done is real
education my opinion and this financial
education and there is no real Financial
education in our school systems and
that's not a mistake
so I um that was in 81 and 83. I
couldn't take it anymore I read I read
brunch of Giants and I understood it
because my Rich Dad kept saying
somebody's messing with us
and every time you say that you know
you're a tin hat guy your aluminum hat
you're a conspiracy you're a spaceship
you're an alien guy and I'm just saying
no I'm an entrepreneur at the time I was
in rock and roll
yeah my first date with Kim was to the
place
you know and and she was out front
having a good time and I wasn't back
with the attorneys negotiating a
contract
so I'm not really a rock and roller but
I'm an entrepreneur and at that time I
said what does God want done not what I
want to do I love rock and roll
and what God wants done is financial
education that was my opinion but the
and so that was in 83. so yesterday you
know and so I don't know if I'm if
that's what I'm supposed to do because
you'll never know you'll never know what
God wants done so I operate on faith the
reason I say only lazy people use their
own money is because it takes much more
intelligence to raise capital
and so I've never been able ever since
my rich dads is a little boy my Rich Dad
forbade me if I'm ever saying I can't
afford it
he says figure out how you can afford it
how can you do something figure out how
you can do something
so over my lifetime most of the projects
I I've started I've I've never had any
money I like not having money because it
forces me to think I get creative I have
to educate myself I have to talk to Rich
guys how did you do this how did you do
that how you do that and what has
happened to me I mean I just turned 72.
I've never needed money
because if I need money I figure out how
to raise it
so today you guys have crowdfunding and
all that I mean I don't know what that
stuff is
but
it's easy to say I can't afford it
all the poor people say I can't afford
it all the poor people say well this tax
they're rich all the poor people are
saying well give me a free education
free food free schooling free manicures
free pedicures
there's laziness my opinion I understand
something I don't have stock spots
mutual funds you know why why I can make
up my own assets hmm I wrote this book
called Rich Dad poured a 31 million
copies to make five dollars a book you
do the math on that one
I create my cash flow game I think I
make six six or seven dollars a game in
50 languages
I know how to sell you go to school get
a job you become an employee but you
learn nothing about taxes
then you become a little entrepreneur
you start your little
Falafel shop business or whatever you
start right so the self-employed small
business and then you have big business
500 employees or more or I for an
investor
so Tom
how much tax do employees pay well
typically if they're making a good
salary and this is by the way the same
rates around the world typically it's
going to be about 40 percent 40 percent
and after the attack the Trump tax cut
did that change much not much
it didn't so if you're a you know oh I'm
going to start my own little business
I'm going to you know start my little
pizza shop or my my coffee shop how much
are these guys pay well now it goes up
because you're paying both it's your
share of the taxes plus the employer
share the the taxes because you've got
both sides so now goes up as high as 60
percent
so when you hear a young person an old
guy like me is saying let's start my own
business they don't have to buy taxes do
they no and in fact this is the place
where people get in trouble because over
here this the money's being taken out of
your paycheck but here you're
responsible for your taxes and so what
happens is that you you go let's say
you're successful with your pizza shop
right all of a sudden tax time comes
around oh no I've spent all my money and
I don't have money to pay the taxes and
people go out of business real fast here
well it is surprising because a lot of
the Millennials do want to start up
their own small little business right
and what they don't they're not aware of
is that they're going to be in a 60 tax
bracket because taxes are your single
largest expense so if you're going to
start your own business you got to be
aware of taxes here now big business as
500 employees or more how much do they
pay typically around the world about 20
percent
now why is it that big business people
pay less than small business well
basically the government wants
the government wants us to do certain
things
incentives if if we do them and what
they want out of a big business is they
want employment so I want to create
employment because that creates
stability in the country jobs jobs right
and so the more jobs you create actually
the more tax benefit you get well look
at Amazon right now they're looking at
moving their company
how many tax benefits are they are
getting oh my Heavens they pay very very
little tax Amazon does and and they pay
you need to talk about all those
different kinds of taxes not only do
they pay very little income tax but
they're also paying very little sales
tax and employment taxes and all those
others because they're getting benefits
from multiple types of government the
federal government state government the
city government is that how is that how
Elon Musk started his battery Factory in
Nevada well yeah I mean Elon Musk he
gets huge research and development tax
benefits which by the way that's a tax
benefit that is TR that is available in
most countries more than the US right
so if you're going to stay small I mean
it's a good place to start but you got
to really want to come over here
eventually
and then the professional investor see
these guys are passive these guys invest
in stocks bonds mutual funds they save
money they're passive guys they pay the
highest taxes
but how much does a professional invest
look it's like Shark Tank
how much do these guys pay so they can
pay as little as zero percent right they
can actually completely eliminate their
tax first word I had to learn at the
mara at the Academy mission mission is
spiritual what's your mission and my
mission has always been to serve people
most people all they give up is making
money and throwing people
it's called the Federal Reserve Bank
Wall Street and all that I wanted to do
with them
so I just don't play their game but you
have to get smarter not to play their
game rule number one in Rich Dad Poor
does the rich don't work for money most
people miss that one but that goes back
to 1971 when Nixon took us out the gold
standard yeah and money became fake
money yeah so anyway
um my rich Act was preparing me to think
about how can I make money without
making without money
and the way I do it I create an asset
like a book
I'm not saying write books because
that's tough industry
but I write a book today I sell 50
licenses
to 50 different languages and I ca I
collect royalties for years a long tail
yeah so my money just keeps coming in
for with that I I borrow so let's say I
make ten dollars in a book
I'll borrow fifty dollars to invest in
real estate I step up my basis for
depreciation hybridization and
appreciation gotcha that's Financial
education yeah yeah that garbage they
teach you about in the festival in the
long term of the stock market why would
I do that when I can make up my own
assets yeah you know that's what
entrepreneurs do every entrepreneur
should be making up their own assets and
staying out of the stock market that's
my point of view but can everybody do it
no of course not sure but I've screwed
up enough times to prove I can do it and
my accountant will back me up yeah the
guy is an idiot but he does create
assets in 1989 when the World Wide Web
came up and the Berlin Wall came down
simultaneously I thought that was
interesting
you know so that was it's another
transformation it's no different than
when you know let's say I'm a king I'm a
king in Portugal or something and I got
all my archers and my swords guys and my
spirit guys and some entrepreneur drives
it up there with his Cannon and he goes
he just loads that can and blows the
guy's walls down you know but that's
kind of what's happening today you know
all the old guys standing in their
castle walls
and some entrepreneurs another pounding
the crap out of them so exactly when I
was with Steve Burke of NBC Universal
he was saying the guys what what we're
doing the guys on social media are
kicking their butts right now they don't
know what to do you know they can't stop
us
so that's kind of what I'm talking about
the problem is the average person
because they went to school looking for
a job they can't see what's going on
they're blind
so you know like and I think was on your
your program you hold up a cell phone
you got more power in that cell phone
than when I first went to the academy in
New York in 65 they had full you know
Rome's blown Sperry computers and all
that you got more power in that cell
phone
then the Sperry computer at my school in
New York
and if you can't make money with that
cell phone
hang up the jock strap man I made a
fortune in 2008. 2020 I'm making more
money I'm paying less taxes
it doesn't mean I don't have problems
but I'm prepared for this my biggest
problem right now is because everybody's
taking a vacation I Can't Get Enough
product
not selling out you know my cash flow
gain is sold out
it's selling out constantly all over the
world all over the world I get royalties
for my book sales my book sales are
going through the roof right now so I'm
making more information yeah there's two
kinds of discipline there's internal or
self-discipline
and then there's external discipline so
right now if the world's kicking your
butt that's externality um
and if you're self-disciplined the
World's kissing your butt right now it's
up to you my poor dad my port my PhD
father he always said to me says you
know I'd be a rich man if I didn't have
your kids
and I said well you know Dad uh
it's not my fault you had kids you know
I mean you know I just can't afford it
because I have kids
and the more he said that the anger I
got
so and I went my rich that age nine you
know he says well that's why you're all
man's poor because he's lazy he thinks
his PhD is going to carry him
he says everybody can say I don't have
money I can't afford it
he says that's why he's poor he's lazy
but my father kept going back to school
you know Stanford University of Chicago
Northwestern he never learned any of
this stuff they still don't know it
because most teachers want a paycheck
pension and tenure they want job
security so the mindset is different
YouTube has the best best teachers this
guy George Gammon man he's a great great
teacher Patrick MC David fantastic
teacher you know uh Cartoon fantastic
teachers
so choose your teachers wisely
that's all that's what I said because I
I have to choose between my rich dad and
my poor dad My Poor Dad PhD poor
helpless and desperate
and that's what he wanted me to do when
I came back from Vietnam was get my
masters are big at my PhD and fly for
the airlines if I had done that
you know my friends who flew for United
they're broke you know why they're broke
because Wall Street stole their pensions
you know it's called an esub employee
stock option plan over my lifetime I've
raised hundreds of millions of dollars
and it's because I don't have I didn't
have money as a young person that I
learned how to raise capital and and
it's really quite simple you have to
find an asset
that's worth more than me you know if
they can't invest in me because that's
called slavery you know you know by me
you know so what I do is you know I
started off I write about it in fake I
started off looking for this one little
piece of Real Estate
I found an excuse you know this one
bedroom one bath condominium on the
beach in Maui
and I found an excuse for people to give
me the money
all I had to do was I sure might pay
them back
so my first deal was an infinite return
deal
I had no money in the deal because it
was 100 debt it was an 18 000 condo you
can't touch them for that much anymore
but the economy was bad
so I buy this eighteen thousand dollar
condo the guy went a 10 down you know
you don't need higher math
10 of 18 000 is how much sports fans
eighteen hundred dollars I could have
used my money I had the money
but that would be too easy number one is
investing us invest in what you love I
love business
I love real estate I mean I really love
it I own this building here
and I love gold and silver
so I invest in what I love
most people say you know and do what you
love but I'd rather invest in what I
love but I love being an entrepreneur I
love investing
it's like Shark Tank to me I'm always
looking at new businesses New Deals it's
just a game like this
you know when you look at the financial
statement that's like a scorecard it's
like a Golf scorecard it's your
financial statement but as you know our
schools teach us nothing about financial
statements that's why you know most guys
wasn't every most major league athletes
they're broke within six years or
something they lose everything sure or a
lottery winner yeah because money never
makes you a rich and so the thing is to
invest in your life experiences your
mentors so the story of Rich Dad Poor
Dad is choosing between two different
teachers you know if I followed My Poor
Dad I'd probably be a government
employee in Hawaii
you know or a tender teacher yeah so
it's it's a hard Choice you've got to
choose your teachers wisely and so
they're talking to this one guy he says
well I have a private pilot's license
okay and then you know guys you know
it's called the big duck he was like big
dog in me I got a private pilot license
I don't even have a license
but I have air medals
if you didn't know what air metal was
you know on air metal just meant how
many how many round trips did you take
into combat and came back alive that's
all I mean it doesn't mean I was a hero
or anything because I wasn't you know
we're just happy to bring my crew back
alive that's all we cared about
but to get to that level of flying
is the same as investing
and I think that's what I really learned
is the dedication not to be to be the
best pilot but be the best that I could
be and I'm not the best that I can be
people die
and a lot of people it's okay to be
average
if you know what I mean but when you get
into that situation when you're going in
and out of combat zones I went down
three times you know but I wouldn't be
back today if I hadn't practiced to be
the best
and so when I go into the world of money
and investing that I'm still not
you know I'm not Zuckerberg or those
guys but
you still have to be the best you want
to you can be
and that's how I can be you know
investing in the stock market with
Diversified stock of
the talk spots which are the ETFs
if you're not willing to get the best
that you can be that's the best for you
you're an average person nothing wrong
with being average
but there's something inside each of us
that wants to be the best at something
when I was reading your uh background I
think that's what you're pushing people
or asking people what do you want to be
the best at
and I just love the Marine Corps I hated
it when I was in it I tell you what
they're not polite
they demanded the best of
so today I carry those traits I went to
military school and then I went to you
know five years of Marine Corps and
flying and all this
so when I hang out with my friends my
friends also want to be the best and so
in some of my books and things I said
look at The Five People You spend time
with
you know if they're not striving to be
the best that's who you are too a big
lesson for you is that it's nothing to
do with the house the car the student
loan it has to do with where's the cash
flowing if the cash is flowing into your
income statement into your pocket
it's an asset it's good debt
but if it's taking money from your
pocket it's
bad debt about that does good debt and
bad debt if you're going to be
successful like whether you're an
employee or entrepreneur you've got to
control the direction of your cash flow
First Property there eight was in Maui
Hawaii in the 1970s I bought it with a
credit card wow property Was Eighteen
thousand dollars my first before but
I've taken several real estate classes
and so I knew what to look for I found
this one property took a long time when
I found it I just broke out my credit
card and bought it and it put 25 in my
pocket I took you know three companies
public through Toronto I mean through
first with VC
Vancouver Stock Exchange and I might
migrate to the Toronto Stock Exchange
why did I do that to learn
learn to how how to raise capital on
public markets
now the average entrepreneur never does
that you know they keep open the pizza
shop and they open two pizza shops and
that's that's about it because they're
into just for that money
I wanted to learn something so I I took
my first
um first was an oil company in Portugal
and I took that public and everybody
told me there's no oil in Portugal and I
found out the hard way they're right
there's no oil there the company crashed
and burned like a airplane coming out of
the sky you know and then the next thing
I started a Silver Company in Argentina
and we struck silver and we did very
well yeah and then I started a gold
company in China and the Chinese took it
so uh
Jesus that was a Priceless experience
you know yeah aren't you better I go
yeah but that's what I did it for you
understand that I did it for that the
tax department which every country has
taxes determined they want to know what
kind of income do you work for
So when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent a parent to the
child
they say it's go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here and the first
thing you pay is the highest taxes
because you worked for money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees or
invest
earned income is what they work for the
second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if I buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand a hundred
thousand is capital gains if I buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest tax so
the tax breaks that President Trump is
working on today is primarily for these
guys here
so they're doctors lawyers
Highly Educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff are
flipping houses you get a break
but with the really which work for
is
passive income and passive income
[Applause]
for me I have a business whether I work
or not money comes in
and you've seen me I'm not here am I no
I never never
I've earned the right not to be here
real estate I get military every year my
wife and I came we had more real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still get this but
this is another type of income
this here I'll get into is called
Phantom income it's taxes I don't pay so
it's a little bit beyond most people's
minds but let's say my tax bill is a
hundred thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break that means
fifty thousand in taxes I don't have to
pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government it went back up
here
so that's what Financial education does
it teaches you about the financial
statement which is not taught in school
again they teach you FICO scores which
is really by those scores
was you told little doggy okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now ironically
when you save money Ava 401k
this is the kind of income so Savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better it's the saving money in
what he called it 401 cases good in this
in Canada it's called rrsp in Australia
called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
I'm an active investor I don't buy this
because this is passive investors I am
active and I'm professional in all of
these areas
so I work for passive income which means
I'm not here the check comes in the
checks come in every year and you've
seen Kim and I and your mother now
she's working on here and so your
mother's income keeps going up your
father's income keeps going up and they
don't have a job the SLS talk you want
to find your soul where is your soul
you know what will sit up you know it's
like when I was when I each time I was
going down
I wasn't flying for me
I was flying for my two young Gunners in
a 19 year old boys really with kids
already
if I didn't do the best job possible
taking that aircraft into the ocean
their kids were fatherless
and I when I meet people who don't have
it in life they don't really have that
soul in them they the soul is there
don't be wrong it's there but you don't
need it yet
So today we're wearing this I think
we're going into a major depression I
hate to say that but are you prepared
for it I'm prepared for it
you know I I wrote a book called Rich
dad's prophecy and I said the biggest
stock market in history was coming in
2016. so the biggest crash in world
history came in March 2020. we're going
out of depression you know hope not
but I would say there's a 60 chance for
a depression now for somebody with a
soul and a spirit it's the greatest
opportunity in history
you know the world's changing I'm going
to get out of this thing these are the
four words income expense asset
liability and the last two words are the
words cash flow and that's why the game
is called
cash flow
and the secret to being rich is not a
college education but can you control
cash flow
and this is what cash flowing looks like
so this here I need this incus has asset
liability
again this is you get a job
and this was my poor dad go to school
get a job get your PhD
and so this here is cash flow so the
income comes in
and it goes out this way first line of
expense is tax
so this is a poor person's cash flow
pattern it's not how much money you make
most people
you know they I don't care if you have a
PhD or no school at all
but they can't control the cash flowing
out through their expenses and so that's
why people like Susie Orman say cut up
your credit cards live below your means
because you're a spendaholic
so that's a poor person this is a middle
class person's cash flow pattern
and this is where the house comes in
they first thing you know most kids do
when they get pay raise and all that
they buy themselves
a bigger house oh my house is an asset
now who tells you that your real estate
agent of course yeah right because they
they wanted to give you this false sense
of security while you're getting screwed
exactly you know but when you look at
what happens with a house a personal I
mean a personal residence something I
live in
the money comes in and goes out and this
is middle class but it also goes out
through a mortgage
mortgage payments all but I don't have a
mortgage you still have taxes you still
you know Hawaii just raised the property
taxes on me which is probably I'm going
to sell I'm going to get out of Hawaii
but you have taxes and you have upkeep
so money is always flowing out
so that's why your house is not an asset
it's because it's taking money from your
pocket so very simply said assets
put money in my pocket liabilities take
money from my pocket
and then this here is so I'm not saying
don't buy a house but here is
a house that I've got
and
I started when I was 25 bought my first
house and it was an apartment it was an
investment property
I didn't live in it I rented it out
and it put money in my pocket
so very simple the definition of asset
and liability is not the house of this
it's cash flow where is the cash flowing
so as a young person and to all
Millennials or if you're old
Financial intelligence is the ability to
control cash flow this is the difference
between rich and poor
the people on this side
are always trying to save money
it makes no sense to save money
because after 1971
the United States took the dollar off
the gold standard
and the dollar became debt
so that people who are saving money are
the Biggest Losers of all
the people who are the biggest winners
are people who know how to use debt to
get rich see debt is money
after 1971 when Nixon took the dollar
off the gold standard money became debt
and so the people who are losers are
Savers so as Kenny says you put your
money in the bank as a saver Kenny goes
in and borrows it out as a debtor and we
use that money to buy millions of
dollars worth of real estate so Kenny
just went over a billion dollars worth
of real estate using debt
but most people say well I can't I can't
do that because I don't have any money
you don't have any money because lesson
number one says the rich don't work for
money
so we learned to use debt to create
assets
and assets keep putting money in our
pocket what is your definition of
greatness
getting up every day
at my age you've got to worry about that
stuff you know I mean I said my plan was
to die at 72.
I almost died so many times so I went
down three times in Vietnam and my days
were numbered from the start of an open
heart surgery I've had cancer I've had
pneumonia I've had malaria
and so you know when everybody talks
about this covid-19 I said I've been
there done that one you know but each
one of it inspired me to get healthier
and so this crisis should inspire people
to get wealthier or you can be a loser
so I don't know why I'm going with that
but it's just
all everything bad is good and
everything good will be bad I got a job
with Xerox because they had sales
training and then for two years I was
the worst salesman they ever had
I was going to get fired from Xerox and
so I went to my Rich Dad and I said in
terms of why what's wrong he says how
many sales calls you make a day I said
on a good day three
he says that's why you're not successful
same formal he says you have to fail
more
he says you got to step up your failure
rate so I found a
non-profit and at night
after working at Xerox I would go to the
phone bank up the street from where I
was working on Honolulu
and I had I had a goal I had to fail 35
times that night
so I just failed 35 times now
interesting thing happened
my numbers at Xerox went up
you see I was handling that fear I was I
was handling the wimp in the couch
and most people don't want to go through
the wimp
and that's why I don't really hang I
don't have much time for it do you know
why they tell you to save money
I don't know
because the system of banking your has
nothing to do with Communism or
capitalism it's the banks Run the World
the rich Run the World they don't care
your communism capitalists
so when you save so let's say you save
one dollar U.S or one Euro one yen the
banking system can lend out 10.
so the entire system is called the
fractional Reserve System
the fractional Reserve System is also
printing money
and then they tell you to save money so
they they want you to save money so they
can lend out your money 10 times
so your dollar became worthless 10 times
over
and then
they used to pay you 10 interest on your
money now it's at best one percent
and they're still lending it out 10
times
so that's why you don't save money is
because your money is becoming worth
less and less and less and less and less
the banks are getting richer and richer
and richer
then they tax you on that interest you
they pay you that one percent interest
if they pay you that much Japan is zero
and the Japanese are so stupid they
still save money
we also have zero yeah and they still
save money how stupid is that
so that's what I have a question so how
come that happens
now if I borrow money guess what do I
pay taxes on debt
I guess no
why is that
I know this is this is what I'm saying
okay question everything okay you saw
when they lent out money
that's how money is created money is
debt they lend out and why is debt
tax-free
I don't know
because that's how money is created
and so the banks love it they love
people borrow lots of money
so how do I get rich I borrow money
and I buy assets with it the poor person
borrows money and buys liabilities like
purses cars houses and they get poorer
and poorer and poorer
but I use
debt I borrowed 300 million after the
crash dollars in 2000 by 2010 I'd
borrowed 300 million dollars to buy real
estate that made me Rich
and the interest rates kept coming down
so my cost of money kept coming down
hence everybody was saying oh you should
get out of debt you know why
because they don't question the hypnosis
they're under you've been hypnotized to
work hard for money to save it the
fractional Reserve System prints it
and then you pay taxes of taxes so I
guess I have all this debt and I get
rich it's a great time to be an
entrepreneur because if you're smart you
have a good spirit and you you learn
quickly see the greatest the greatest
thing about entrepreneurs how fast can
you learn
you know when you look at the seven
deadly sins
the biggest tragedy is ego
is it ego or van glory is the road
Straight to Hell
and so you got to be I tell you I've
made mistakes I tell you I screw it up
I'm definitely not the shortlist for
saint
but you'd better be honest and people
trust you and you better keep your word
you know you're only as good as your
word yeah so actions and words must be
in integrity that's why in 1997 I
created the cash flow 96th grade the
cash flow board game it's the only game
that teaches you accounting by having
fun
so the cash flow game I'd play at least
10 times because each time you play
learn something new well what what the
game is doing because you have to move
move pieces and write and all this stuff
is moving your neural Pathways you have
to train you know the most important
thing is change the neural Pathways in
your brain
and and the brain is driven driven by
your heart
and when I meet somebody with an
employee's brain they say I want job
security
I want I want a good pension does that
have medical benefits that's their brain
that's them I can't help them they're
going to rewire the brain yeah
because the economy takes place between
this year and this year that's where the
economy takes place and in your heart
and in your guts I started playing
Monopoly
I was nine years old and everybody's
played Monopoly except I played in real
life
you know four greenhouses one red Hotel
tax-free
and if you really if you're really gonna
learn to be rich you have to learn how
to sell how to use debt and how not to
pay taxes that's the game that's why I
said when I saw that that iPhone come
out I said all you Millennials are all
you entrepreneurs out there that cell
phone is your lifeline how did this mess
use it so what we're doing today is
anti-fragile you know we're wartime
leaders
and we're going to come out of this
better I don't know how
but it's called metamorphosis in a
metamorphosis is like when a butterfly
and a caterpillar turns into a butterfly
that's metamorphosis
and the definition of metamorphosis you
can look it up the dictionary
is the trend or the transformation from
an immature form to an adult form
immature form to adult form in other
words grow up
so for some of us this crisis will will
grow up will come of an anti-fragile
will come out stronger and that's why
I've been watching my tweets I say you
know the best teachers are on YouTube
not in school
because most School teachers and this is
Jordan Peterson is saying he said Jordan
Peterson is being attacked by his own
School teachers
because they are [ __ ] you know
they're all these guys and they tend
they're they're job security they need
protection the world's a terrible Place
capitalists are Crooks and all this
stuff
and it's a free country you can listen
to those guys if you want or you can
listen to Pat Patrick McDavid so your
thing on the military leader versus the
peacetime leader was prescient it was
the most important lessons everybody
should look at they have to ask yourself
today
am I going to be a military leader and
come out of this anti-fragile and
stronger better healthier or am I going
to be crushed by what Fuller called
grunch the gross Universal cashless I
encourage anybody listening to this or
any entrepreneur
get to the point where you don't need
money it's called the infinite return
and that's my my next book coming out
next year yeah when you get to the point
where you don't need money
free
you'll never need money you don't care
you could always put a deal together
you can always create an asset out of
nothing you know it's like
I don't know what up it's the power of
god-given power
so like I said when I write a book I'm
selling 50 copies 50 licenses day one
and let's say I got ten thousand a
license how much is that 50 times 10 000
is it 500 000. fifty times ten thousand
yeah that yeah 100 000. yeah so I'm in
I'm in the black immediately what does
it cost me maybe ten thousand to write a
book
do you know so I'm in the black
the same thing if I trade a stock I'll
buy a stock a dollar it goes up to 10
and I sell
so I have all free trading stock I have
no money in it that's what Buffett's
doing they're all infinite return guys
sure you have no money into the deal and
you can do it with anything today if you
know people complain I don't make enough
money in Romania well you have a cell
phone you can make money all over the
world you can't make money in dollars
yeah and Slot Nick pesos you know it's
just limited thinking if a person
doesn't change what's inside their head
the actual thoughts running their brain
which are words
they'll never change so the change
begins when you question go to school
get a job work hard pay taxes save money
get out of debt and invest in the stock
market until you until you question that
one nothing changes there's three kinds
of income this ordinary portfolio
passive So when you say to some poor kid
go to school get a job
they're working for ordinary the highest
tax income in the world
I don't work ordinary I don't want a
paycheck
passive income is generally what happens
when you invest in the stock market
I mean portfolio income
so they say well I bought Tesla at 100
it went up to 200 I sold it so I made a
hundred dollars that's portfolio
that's tax at the next higher level
so when I have passive income
it's
tax-free
getting passive income you have to know
what you're doing so that's why the best
first of all bookkeeper accountants
attorneys bankers
I operate as a team just like my my when
we flew into combat or a team
and most people are trying to do it
self-employed way
you know I'm a good computer programmer
good you pay the highest taxes you work
the hardest you don't get a head that
way
but that's what most people they want to
do it on their own you know if you
weren't done right
do it by yourself
and an employee is always saying the
same words this year and this year
I'm looking for a safe secure job with
benefits and a paycheck and a pension
that you got that
that's what they're looking for so if I
have a job I'll help
and a self-employed person say how are
you good I'm the best
good I'll hire the best
but the government's going to penalize
you for that because you're because
you're working for a blended income well
that's more passing it's actually
ordinary income but um
pay the highest taxes the tax law are
nothing but incentives not punishments
so if you donate if I I just donated uh
money to the food bank because they're
out of a lot of food so it's ten
thousand bucks I get a tax bill
I don't donate money to the debt food
bank no tax break
so because I have 7 000 rentals in
apartment houses
I got a tax break you know why because
I'm providing policy
and because I have thousands of
employees the tax break the government
even sent me money to pay my employees
what do you recommend people do in a
market that is potentially heading into
depression should they be saving cash
and thinking about you know becoming
more liquid like what are some of the
things that they should do well it
depends upon the cash
if you're if you're in Argentine is it
right pesos yeah
I wouldn't touch it
I'd say of gold and silver
so what's his name uh what's his head
edgewater's head no Bridgewater sky ray
dalio yeah he says it depends upon the
currency you're in sure he says so like
Zimbabwe their debt is financed with
external money Japan is internally
financed
so that's why the depression doesn't
hurt them as badly so you have to learn
so much about that
so I own millions and millions and
millions and millions and millions in
Gold because I started buying gold in
1973 when it was illegal for Americans
to own gold
and I like gold and silver because
there's no counterpartier risk there's
no other party to it gold and silver are
God's money so people say well it's not
a good investment I said yeah but
I sleep at night what's that worth
yeah sure so I don't care if the dollar
the dollar is corrupt the US dollar is
corrupt but it's the strongest currency
in a horrible currency world yeah so if
you're a U.S save dollars
you're in Argentina don't save gold
right save Bitcoin you think Bitcoin
would be I mean Bitcoin has got its
problems too but I'm just saying I would
so when you say save money you got to
say what what currency yeah what
currency the very guys that went to the
schools the best schools created these
fake assets to make themselves and the
six major Banks richer than ever before
they produce sugar highs of immediate
profits but separated those taking the
risk from those who would bear the
consequences so the way out of it is for
financial education
and you can do it everybody can do it
but you have to understand the game
after 1971 this is what happens to
people who save money the purchasing
power of the dollar is going down
because they're printing money and our
school Futures these fake teachers again
they're good people all these financial
planners still tell you to save money
well why would you save money when these
guys are printing it faster than you
could ever ever save it
that's bad teaching bad financial advice
horrible so it says and then the second
to tell you to save money and invest for
the long term in the stock market this
guy is saying I said are you nuts
this is Stockman he was Reagan's budget
director he's a real teacher he was
there
just the whole stock market is rigged
for the rich again it's a casino and a
casino is based depends upon all these
losers coming in so those the top can
win so the losers started coming in
right around here
1974.
it was a thing called the 401K
they needed more losers to enter the
market
and went to the financial planners tell
you save money and invest for the long
term in the stock market they needed
people to come in here and push this up
again it's a casino like Las Vegas
a lot of losers walk in winners walk out
with the money that's the game now again
it was glass-steagall they organized
hedge funds that turn owning a stock
into a minute to minute bet rather than
invest for the long term it's a casino
we don't know when but it will come down
then all those guys those 401ks toast
that's why the Rich Dad company was
formed that's why I catch so much hell
saying Savers are losers you know
why invest for the long term in the
stock market when it's a casino my
concern is my the old guys like me
are sitting there with their retirement
plans which are broke
you know the California retirement
system is broke Hawaii retirement system
is broke Chicago's retirement system is
broke and if and when this baby comes
down my generation is toast the way out
is for Real Financial education most
people are afraid of debt
you asked if you go home tonight
and you say well they talk to me about
using debt
and most people go like this
because they don't teach you about money
see debt is money
after 1971 when Nixon took the dollar
off the gold standard money became debt
and so the people who are losers are
Savers so as Kenny says you put your
money in the bank as a saver Kenny goes
in and borrows it out as a debtor and we
use that money to buy millions of
dollars worth of Real Estate
so kind of just went over a billion
dollars worth of real estate using debt
but most people say well I can't I can't
do that because I don't have any money
you don't have any money because lesson
number one says the rich don't work for
money
so we learned to use debt to create
assets
and assets keep putting money in our
pocket if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it's going to be the
biggest adventure of your life as long
as you want to keep learning
but if you just want to make a few bucks
you'll be taxed to death yeah that's the
S quadrant espi that's the problem
and as you know small business loans are
not they don't give me any money
hard to raise Capital as an S you're in
crowdfunding all that stuff but I'd
rather go to Wall Street I'd rather
raise my own Capital yeah but those are
skill sets
so I say to every entrepreneur look at
it as the biggest education plan you'll
ever go through you know I don't care if
a college degree or not
but you better you better learn really
quickly fast have good people around you
and keep studying in 89 the World Wide
Web came up so exactly as he predicted
so all you young Millennials out there
and young people you have the most
powerful tool ever created in humanity
the question is how are you going to use
it you can use that iPhone the way we're
doing it right now to educate to inspire
to teach
or you can watch porno on it what's up
to you
it's really up to you it's like soccer
and rugby are two different games two
different types of players
and since my wife's a golfer you know I
play golf but I'm not I don't enjoy the
game she's fanatical
but she would be an S you know
self-employed type and all this stuff
she's going to do it on her own I I
cannot do my job on my own I cannot go
in the Rugby field by myself
and when I go into the field of business
I don't go by myself bookkeeper
accountants attorneys bankers and
whatever else and that's how we play the
game the biggest thing I can say to any
entrepreneurs is
learn be an active learner low ego be
you know it's tough when you're
successful
because when my nylon and vertical
Surfer while the business went to the
moon I was crashing down right after it
it went straight
yeah it went straight to bed I thought I
walked on water except there was no
water it was the only air below me
so having the hard way you know I don't
I don't learn it easy if you've served
in the military you'll understand what
real courage is and that was the word I
got and I went to military school in New
York only because I was such a screwed
up kid in Hawaii surfing all the time
and so I needed some discipline
and when I meet people who are not
successful they'll act discipline
it's not that they're not smart you know
they can't it's not save money they
can't budget money the property
was a little condominium
one bedroom
one bath
eighteen thousand dollars
U.S
it was on the beach of Maui
the reason the price was so low is the
market had crashed
smart investors always wait for the
crash
so this thing crashed
I had to look at 100 properties once I
left the class three-day class I had to
look at 100 properties in 90 days
and write a one-page report on each of
those properties
as my instructor said to me when I left
that three-day class I was 26 years old
and the instructor says your education
begins when you leave the class
as your education will begin when you
leave this class
not now
so you have a chance to talk to Carlos
you have a chance to talk to Alvaro
talk to them find out learn doesn't cost
you any money
change your ideas
so with this here the instructor said
I had to borrow buy the investment for
zero money
okay
zero money
most people will tell you
I can't invest because I don't have
money
that's a loser
please understand this
this was 1974.
the dollar had just gone off the gold
standard everything was coming up fast
so
I had to figure out how to buy it for
zero
and the reason I say that is most poor
people like Padre pobre always says I
can't afford it
I know some of you right now say well I
can't afford it I don't have time I have
children I have a job I have bills to
pay and it is those excuses that keep
you poor if you did not change that talk
in your head you will always be the poor
person
so there was about 32 in my class three
days long I think only three people
completed the exercise
we went we looked at 100 properties
wrote a one-page report
at the end of the 90 days in 100
properties this was the best property
so I went back to the person
and it was in bankruptcy it was right on
the beach just as pretty as a speech
here
and he said I had to have
two thousand dollars down this is called
equity
again it's the language of money so I
have equity
the bank was going to lend me
[Music]
six thousand and
debt
right that was the deal
now I had the 2000 in cash
but the name of the game or the exercise
was could I buy it for zero
so what I did
was I paid for this property
with a credit card
so now it was
thank you
100 debt
okay
with that hundred percent debt
I made
twenty five thousand dollars a month
boom
I was a free human being
I never needed money again
if you can make money with no money
that is called
an infinite return
because I have no money in the deal
one thing for these people right now is
choose your teachers wise and I commend
you for attending to help people as if I
could leave anything to you the people
that are listening to you right now
commendable
they're they're looking they're looking
for answers
like it comes back down to who are your
five friends
and are you happy with it or is
attacking move on and our job is to be
wartime leaders
and be brave be courageous
get our skills up get an entrepreneurial
skills up you know learn to sell learn
to communicate don't learn you know my
problem Patrick is I infuriate people
because I attack them
being a marine is not bright
because I like to fight and that's why I
had to go to military school to
discipline myself
so that's if any if any of you out there
you know have young people
you know I have a lot of friends whose
sons are lips
there's just whips
you know that's sitting at home sucking
their thumb
and then now that they lost their job
they want to go back and get a job or
exactly as you said they'll make more
sitting at home sucking their thumb
and they've lost another generation
there
so it really is time to be a wartime
leader Taekwondo is all all forms legs
you know kicking
so I stuck that on my back on my head so
I went to watch The Rock Marines train
when these guys they have no feelings
they're just tough tough tough they make
great entrepreneurs though now yeah
they're nasty they're a lot of good guys
but you know they're tough let's go in
so I came back to the States and I took
up Taekwondo
and I still stuck at it but you know I
took it up and you have a black belt
Roll come on yeah well American black
belt first I see I see it there's a
difference of American black belt
Taekwondo and a Korean black belt and
Taekwondo you know so I got over there
and I fight for them for America
okay that's amazingly I got my butt
handed well let me explain to you
I was a heavyweight which means I was
fat in America
in Korea they're tall and skinny like
you yeah and Koreans and Taekwondo is
about the legs really
they could it's called a cheeky or the
hammer they could lift the legs straight
over their heads
and they stand there on one leg and they
just watch you
claimately he looks like
this leg in the air and I'm this little
fat guy trying to come up
you know how do I find that opening here
so I mean you're like you could barely
get up here I can't lift my legs so I
get into the ring I said this is not
fair but but he's a heavyweight but he's
a skinny heavyweight right but his legs
are like no no really he's tall he was
like six foot four his legs are probably
eight feet high and they I don't know
how high heels up in the air I couldn't
come in on him so I made the mistake I
said well no guts no glory I jumped in
on that leg came across my head and I
was out
if you're going to be a real
entrepreneur you're you have to be a
lifelong learner I am studying learning
constantly I never stop
and that's my competitive Advantage but
also my core advisor team we never
stopped together
you know I have my accountants my
attorneys my bankers and all that we
study together
that's what we do we get together we
don't play golf we don't drink beer we
study
because study is the way you win but you
have to know what you're studying
because you know what you put in here
garbage in garbage out right I think you
have to be careful is it who's your
teacher who's your mentor
you know I took golf lessons once at the
Biltmore
and um
those most horrible golf lessons I ever
had
because that was a golfer the teacher
and I just did not get along
so they brought a new golf instructor
and and I learned to love the game again
you know what I mean so as an
entrepreneur I'd be very careful who
your teacher is
because they can either
kill your spirit or increase your spirit
a good teacher will inspire you to learn
more
a bad teacher will tell you you're
stupid and you should study more most of
your viewers out there is sitting inside
their head other words from their mother
and father go to school
get a job
pay taxes
save money buy a house because it's an
asset get out of debt yeah and invest in
the stock market
that creates poor people
it's a hypnosis train going through your
brain so when people say how do I change
my life well you change those words
I wouldn't go to school
because you learned nothing about money
in school
ask I wouldn't get a job because if I
have a job I'm an employee
and then I'd pay taxes and I don't pay
taxes
and I don't save money
and I use debt to get rich and I don't
invest in the stock market that's why
I'm rich
and so the young people who are
listening right now they're saying but
that's what my mom and dad said
but that's what Mom and Dad say all over
the world
so to the young people I just say
challenge or question what you've been
taught
because from the Bible I'm not religious
yeah the word becomes flesh so if you
say go to school they say but I learned
nothing about money
get a job or you become an employee yeah
if you're an employee you work for money
I pay taxes
then they tell you to save money why
would you save money when the
government's printing money
you know and get out of debt
well debt is money
I use debt to get rich most people use
debt to get poor and invest in the stock
market I don't invest in the stock
market
so when you when you wonder why so many
people struggle financially because they
haven't challenged the hypnosis the
words go to school
get a job
work hard
save money get paid taxes until you
question those hypnotic chances
you don't change question I ask you is
are you following the herd
you know the herd generally goes off the
cliff like a bunch of lemmings
how many are doing what your mommy and
daddy told you what to do
go to school get a job invest in a
well-diversified portfolio stock spots
mutual funds and ETFs
is that what you're doing
are you hoping that the next person
elected whether it's president Trump or
one of the other candidates will save
the economy
well we have a very important show for
people like you
because this program is about you have
to do the exact opposite
of what everybody else is doing because
if you keep doing what everybody's doing
I'm afraid everybody's going to go off
the cliff and that Cliff is not too far
away right now what I found out the
accounts and attorneys who went to the
biggest schools are not the best
I have found what I'm looking for is
somebody who may be a private guy who is
passionate about entrepreneurship so
there are great attorney for
entrepreneurs
you know they're not you know most
attorneys looking for the big client
like I want to work for
you know General Electric
what I want is the attorney and the
account who are passionate about it
being entrepreneurs
so my
my guys right here in Phoenix are
entrepreneurs
and my accountants are entrepreneurs
every time I hire the big name corporate
and law
accounting firms I have been grossly
overpaid and underserved because they're
so used to doing bigger things they
don't have time for a little guy like me
it's the same with bankers
I'm looking for a banker who loves being
an entrepreneur you know you got to have
this partnership with the bank you know
I I dump on the financial services
industry a lot and they deserve to be
dumped on
but you gotta have fun on your team you
know so my banker is the love of my life
the biggest thing for most young people
is that our schools teach us to be ICS
into independent contractors okay or
self-employed or even if you're an
employee you're still an independent
contractor as a job
and you do it by yourself you know I
think you know I think I think much of
it much of the young world is in the
selfie world you know look at me look at
me look at me whereas in my world it's a
team sport I'm a rugby player I go on
the field with a team toughest meanest
guys I know
and so you could be that you could be
the a student from Princeton but I go on
this field with 15 tough men kick your
ass
and so the average guy is coming out
there
you know like oh I got an A I went to
Princeton I went to Harvard and
Corporate America comes out and they go
boom
so that's why when I talk to young
people I say look it's a team sport
so the first person I have is a
bookkeeper bookkeeper is the lowest paid
person on my team but the most important
right
the bookkeeper then keeps the accurate
records that my accountant can use and
my attorney can use and my banker can
use
that's the combination there am I Banker
my attorney and my account must work
together as a team
most people their Bankers accountants
and attorneys don't work for those teams
because in school we're taught to take
our tests on our own
if you ask for help you're cheating
in my world is called cooperation
and what I found with most smart people
they don't know how to cooperate they
don't know how to ask for help
because in their brains that's cheating
it means you're stupid it means you're
awake
means you're stupid one of the things I
stress here at Rich Dad which I never I
didn't do for much of the time was
because
once Kim and I had enough money the
question is what do you do next
and if Kim and I had continued to work
for money I think I would have died
so when Kim retired she was 37 and I was
47. but just as we said on this with
vonte it's one of your primary
objectives especially today
is when do you plan to retire
because you know the idea of having a
job and waiting for your 401k or your
stock market to save you I think you're
going to be sadly disappointed because
what I'm forcing is a massive crash
coming it's going to wipe out a lot of
people
and I'm coming up with a new book called
who stole my pension and all these guys
who think their pension is safe
I think Wall Street has other ideas on
their pension here
so when I say to young people like you
guys I said you know plan your
retirement the day you start working
you know when do you escape from the rat
race that's the cash flow game well as
we know there's fewer and fewer jobs you
know American corporations say they're
hiring but they're not hiring in America
they're hiring overseas
but more than that is that the reason I
endorse network marketing is most people
are addicted to the paycheck
and the paycheck is one of the most
Sinister plots ever pulled upon a human
being if you need a paycheck you've sold
your soul
you know your sold your body your mind
your spirit and your emotions you'll sit
there in fear of losing your job or can
I get a raise or you know will I get
promoted
I mean and then and then
why would you do that another thing
about we endorse network marketing we
don't think of it as a network marketing
we think of it as entrepreneur
development because if you need a
paycheck this is not your business you
know we build businesses so sometimes
when Kim and I do a deal we we may not
receive a paycheck for five six years
you know and so these guys come am I
going to get rich quick you know and
some people do I don't know you do or
not but that does an employee get rich
loser mindset and so the thing that
network marketing does is really kind of
cure you of that loser paycheck get rich
quick mentality and actually build a
business you know we build businesses
but and that's how we're rich but we
didn't get rich quick and I don't need a
paycheck I never want a paycheck so
that's kind of a revolutionary thought
to most people up there who went to
school to get good grades and get a job
you know they get a high paying job and
the higher paying job you pay higher
taxes and you wonder why you never get
ahead that's because you went to school
to get a job and a paycheck you've got
to get away from the paycheck and
sometimes it might take two three years
to get away from that a big part of what
makes a company successful is whether or
not they have a brand b-r-a-n-d almost
misspelled it okay
and brand people think well it's the
communication you know but a brand is
more than that the reason rich dad is so
valuable right now is because it is an
internationally known brand the same way
as Trump is known as a brand and the
real question on a brand is not just
communication see a brand makes it
easier to sell when somebody says Rich
Dad think oh I think I heard of that or
I know what the guy stands for and all
this so what a brand really is is the
entire bi triangle if you're going to
create a brand especially in a world
that's overcrowded with advertising
communication the webs iPods print blogs
I mean there's so much competition now
for a person's time it really is more
important that you become a brand so
there's a shortcut communication like if
I say the word Ferrari you know you get
a picture of something in your mind it's
a whole body effect but if I said
Hyundai or Kia in a car they're probably
just as good a car but you get a whole
different emotional effect just by the
brand name so I'm not saying Hyundais
are better or worse than a Ferrari but
I'll pay more for Ferrari than I will
for a Hyundai I don't own 100 by the way
I own a Ferrari what does it mean it's a
shortcut communication like if I say the
word Apple you know some people think of
computers and some people think of red
apple
but for the guys like me who are I'm an
apple fanatic you know the brand means a
lot to me I love Steve Jobs he's one of
the best entrepreneurs in the world
right now
and if I say the word Marine Corps
Marine Corps is a brand it communicates
everything the mission the team the
leadership the style the message and the
Marines have a saying we're only looking
for a few good men and women that means
we just don't want to be like the Army
we have to position ourselves away from
the Army the Air Force and the Coast
Guard and the Navy
so brands are so vitally important as a
communication tool especially in today's
over-communicated to World there are
more people competing for your customers
mind their time you know how many blogs
can you read how many magazines can you
read how many television sets can read
how many games can you play and all this
so today if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it becomes more and more
important that you become a brand there
are people who want to go into real
estate but they have the they have the
negative Midas Touch everything they
turn they touch turns to [ __ ] you know
it doesn't turn to gold and then no
matter what piece of real estate or
another what stock they go into they
have a loser's mentality and that's why
I don't hang out with losers well I'm a
good hard-working person I say I know
but you're a laborer you're not an
investor you don't understand me but I'm
a good person I go to church every
Sunday I work hard
I said yeah but you're still a loser
it doesn't mean you're a bad person does
that make sense you guys here you're a
loser you're a financial
little sir
that's what it means it doesn't mean I
don't want a bad partner I only became
an entrepreneur because it was the
greatest challenge I could take on as
far as my personal education personal
development yeah
and it wasn't to make money you know and
as I said my first business was a nylon
and velcro Surfer wallet business and
the mistake I made I was successful and
we grew internationally so fast I just
couldn't Finance My Success
and so I started borrowing money and
which was good I started to learn how to
raise capital I learned I learned how to
negotiating um you know in the reason I
was in Korea fighting Taekwondo was I
was out there negotiating anyway for
production because we were Manufacturing
in Hawaii with a cost of manufacturing
was too too high sure so I had to fly to
Korea and Taiwan to negotiate
Manufacturing
I tell you man you're not stupid until
you're negotiating against Koreans and
Taiwanese man those guys had me coming
and going up one side and down the other
but that's what I did it for you know
what I mean it's to learn and to learn
to finance learn how to factor you know
how to how to ship and then Factor my
inventory and all this stuff and I
learned so much as I was going broke
successfully going broke and so when I
explained to young people that's what I
did it for that's so that's how you get
smarter but in this academic culture you
know we're just talking about Jordan
Peterson how he he rails up against
academics well the academic culture the
person who makes the most mistakes is a
stupid person
but an entrepreneur the person that
makes the most mistakes and learns from
them is the smart is the rich person so
I always say that young entrepreneurs
it's not money will never make you rich
you know it's your experience you know
how much you learn the mistakes you make
the people you make
and all of those horrible experiences
they're all good experiences if you
learn from them sure and that's the
attitudinal difference of an
entrepreneur most guys are small
business guys they're not entrepreneurs
you know they open a pizza shop to make
money and they get stuck in that pizza
shop forever you know well that's not me
and the subject of entrepreneur
is a massive subject so you get a drug
dealer peddling drugs is also an
entrepreneur as is Jeff Bezos running
the biggest product pushing country in
the company in the whole world they're
both entrepreneurs but the gap between
the drug dealer and Bezos massive so
when I speak to young people I said what
kind of entrepreneur do you want to be
and if you're just here to make money
since you know you can do that but it's
not exciting I'm trying to explain to
you when they tell you get out of debt
that's stupid because the money is debt
and the only way money gets out of debt
is via taxes so all the people who work
for money you're at Rich Dad Poor Dad
what's lesson number one
rich people don't work for money correct
money is debt
I use debt as money
and everybody thinks getting in debt is
bad well who told you that
I think the stock market is for losers
why would you put money in the stock
market when it's manipulated
that's what I think about so I'm always
watching the manipulation going on
behind the scenes
that's what my brain is focusing on all
the time and I don't pay taxes the
question is how is it I don't pay taxes
I can tell you
that's like that's an important question
because most people are so most
Romanians and most people in the United
States cheat on their taxes because they
hate taxes so much but you don't have to
cheat on taxes if you understood how
money was working
you think Donald Trump pays taxes
no
nobody has seen his tax returns yeah I
know him he's my friend
we don't pay taxes
that's the question how is it we do that
that's an intelligent question the
reason you can't ask me this question
because you don't know how I do it
that's why I keep saying to the young
the Millennials you know if they're a
pack of whips
you know I meet Millennials who are just
horrifyingly weak snowflakes I call them
you know yeah they go to college at
floor mats that taught trigger events or
whatever you know the the I don't know
what they say today but they've got to
have special rooms where there's no
whatever I'm going holy mackerel Welcome
to the Real World you know and there's
other Millennials who are as tough as
Nails I mean this is the biggest
opportunity they've ever had right now
the book I'm reading is a personal
development book is called Happiness
morning that's number one and the second
book is called the happiness the miracle
morning and and Happiness Advantage
one's written by Harvard
a teacher The Happiness Advantage
fantastic book and the other book is
Miracle morning written by an
entrepreneur and they say the same
things but in different ways so I read
both of them three times because they're
so powerful but I'm working on me
you see there's no the economy out there
is just the economy
if you think it's a bad economy it's
because you're a bad economy is here
if you think it's you know those jobs
are tough
that's because that's you in here as any
entrepreneur knows it's always a good
economy no matter which way it's going I
can almost make some money it's always
good it's always opportunity so I've got
to protect the spirit or the
entrepreneurial mindset inside of me so
when the markets crash I make more money
unfortunately for the average person
without Financial education the guy who
invested for the long term for job
security their house is an asset and all
that stuff they got wiped out that's
what happened in 2007 right here
they got wiped out by the crash and
others got richer by the crash and
that's the difference people trying to
do good by educating outside of the
Traditional School System where they're
I think they're more limited correct and
that's why I created the cash flow board
game is because I learned about it I
learned about money playing Monopoly
yeah I learned more about life playing
Monopoly than I did in four years of
college yeah how much I really look at
school you know the best schools in the
world U.S Merchant Academy
that came out a rich man
but it didn't teach me much about money
I was only a high-paid employee I just
think about the economy business okay
world affairs I I want to my job is to
make complex Financial systems simple
enough to the average person can
understand it that is extremely
difficult
because most people are brainwashed when
it comes to money
go to school
get a job work hard pay your taxes save
money get out of debt buy a house and
invest in a stock market everybody who
follows that program is been brainwashed
I don't even care about money I make a
lot of money because I understand the
system
I would never go to school get a job
work hard save money get out of debt buy
a house and invest in a stock market I
do everything exactly opposite several
things that I I find one more time
second book cash flow quadrant es on the
right side is BNI and that's again
that's where guys like Mark Cuban and
Damon Johns come from you know their
their professional investors they
acquire companies finance companies they
have what's called family offices not
not home businesses or family home
offices they're family offices so I have
a family office so when I when I was a
young man my rich dad said to me someday
you want a family office I said what
does that mean I got an office he goes
no no no no
yes we have a whole team of people
moving your money for you because you
got so much money coming in
say too much money is a problem also
because you got to keep moving it
so I have a family office and that was
part of the whole process of becoming
rich was so I could learn to have a
family office and the average guy is a
401k why am I kicking his butt I don't
care if he went to Harvard
you know I'll kick his butt up one side
and down the other making millions not
paying taxes but keep moving my money I
don't have a job I've only had one job
and I never wanted a job after that
because I had to be hungry not to say
you know but we're all different we're
humans we're different beings especially
this diagram here you know it's why I
created my cash flow board game because
we have four different intelligences we
had mental intelligence we have I don't
know what that one is physical
intelligence
you probably have very good physical to
make you know football and all that yeah
emotional intelligence but spiritual
intelligence
so I went to military school in New York
the first thing is spiritual
you know I become a Marine it's
spiritual yeah you know what I mean
because you're putting your life on the
freaking line yeah you know so nazim
Talib you know wrote the book The Black
Swan he also wrote uh anti-fragilies
this is three kinds of people in the
world there's fragile and that's where
school systems are putting out fragile
would be snowflakes and that's your
choice you want to be that way have a
good life the second type is that sauce
a fragile is like a champagne flute yep
you hit at the shatters
then the second one is called robust
and a robust person is like The Rock
you know you can pound on them dump on
them yeah they
take it
but that's all they do they take
and that anti-fragile is somebody like
you where they pound the crap out of you
and you get smarter and better because
so I love nauseam Talib you know a lot
of people call them Dr Doom but
the way I look at this whole thing this
economist we're publicly under
depression you know we're not going to
get out of this really oh yeah and so
the thing is is this good for you or bad
for you I'm looking forward to it you
know the last the last crash was 2008.
and I made more money in 2008 than in my
whole life
so this one here two thousand you know
what is it 2020. I'm going to get even
richer
but I'm gonna get poor and if they're
Baby Boomers they're going to blame it
on this coronavirus oh my health you
know the hey hit the road put on some
running shoes change your diet get some
sunlight you know get healthy don't go
don't be a wimp but oh no I'm so afraid
of dying I'm going you're already dead
you don't even know it yet you know in
the Marine Corps you know in the Marine
Corps we used to call them corpse people
right corpse not core yeah of course no
corpseman a corpseman is a person who's
dead but doesn't know it what should the
people understand about this way of
living because we cannot all be
entrepreneurs some people need to get
some jobs or should we all try and look
at how we can change our lives in in the
way you show it in your books
and your Keynotes it's up to the person
it's up to the person it's a free free
choice you want to be an employee you
choose to be an employee
you want to be an entrepreneur you
choose to be an entrepreneur but you've
got to study that do two different
people
what you have to study is different
mentally emotionally and spiritually
they're different people and
entrepreneur is extremely different than
an employee
but it's a different study the troubled
is our school system trains us to be
employees
go to school get a job work hard save
money pay your taxes get out of debt and
invest in the stock market that makes
you poor the biggest thing for an
entrepreneur is you've got to learn how
to make mistakes
and the school punishes you making
mistakes
second you have to operate in a team
you know everybody talks about team
except in school if you take tests as a
team you call it cheaters
so just those two minds constructs the
average guy goes out there afraid of
making a mistake and starts a business
in the next mistakes obviously
then they don't have a team because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one I did
recently with Grant check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created and best
Elon Musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses